I'm John Stanley I'm a photographer with
National Geographic magazine here on
assignment for part six of the out of
Eden walk we started at Africa in 2013
in January and we've been walking
Overland doing slow journalism and now
we're in as Becca Stan
[Music]
we're out to look for the ancient
Caravan routes of Delhi a caravan
stopped from the 14th century so a third
attempt to get to these ancient ruins
first time was by motorbike and that
didn't work the second was a tractor
that didn't show up and now it comes
already stuck we also picked up a little
friend you seem to be making headway
about 30 kilometers to go running into a
tragic situation here keep getting stuck
in the snow and he'll only is right
there I don't know if we're gonna make
it before the Sun Goes Down just
literally seconds now figure out our way
back through the darkness we've got
thirty kilometers just to go back to the
road and then it was worth every bit of
it the RLC has retreated more than 200
kilometers from this point in is becca
stan and all that remains are the
rusting beauty of ships still at their
mooring but the shoreline used to be we
came here specifically because i wanted
to come here over winter and hope there
was snow on the ground released for the
snowing and by chance there is not as
much snow as I was hoping but at least
there's a canopy one of the biggest
challenges I have on these kind of
stories is how to make the visuals
interesting many many people have
photographed this before and the
challenges how do you take it further
[Music]
we're here in some Otakon I'm trying to
make some pictures I try to look for
something interesting see something
interesting especially in a place like
the bazaar that's so well photographed
there's no smelting and there's this
fantastic torrents of water coming out
I'm hoping it'll make something of a
picture and all this is not actually
knowing if any of this is going to work
trying again take the ordinary and
hopefully find something
airy thanks for joining us Julia good
Aghori at working the film camera and
also Ozzy's public push the car
[Music]